Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
June 10,
2019 what's going on out?
Why?
Yeah,
June
tenths.
Uh,
my birthday,
happy birthday to me.
Happy Birthday to me.
Happy 51st birthday dear pace.
The
happy birthday to me.
Um,
all right.
Before I get on with my,
uh,
birthday stuff,
real quick,
very relieved as I'm sure most people are.
Why wouldn't you be that David Ortiz is going to be okay.
Looks like.
And they said there was no collateral damage,
meaning no damage to his organs,
which is also great.
Um,
thank God.
Thank God I got the,
I was fortunate enough to meet him one time I did a roast.
I'm with Josh Wolfe and all those guys a couple of years ago and uh,
he could not have been,
he was,
he was just such a nice guy and you know,
and love the more you trashed in the morning.
He loved,
it was such a fun night.
And
um,
who the hell shoots David Ortiz?
You know,
let's live it.
It's like shooting Santa Claus.
I don't understand why somebody would do that.
Um,
I saw a video,
it seems like,
uh,
other people in the immediate vicinity agreed and,
did to him.
What would have happened if you shot Santa Claus?
Was she got the shit kicked out of them?
Um,
yeah.
What a world of all the fucking people.
I just don't even understand it and didn't even seem like it was a robbery.
It was just trying to kill him.
Is there one of those lunatics like that guy who tried to shoot Reagan just so
you can get famous?
I don't get it,
but fortunately he's going to be okay.
And uh,
all of that stuff.
So good for that.
And a shout outs to a Aaron and Fred at Rivington music studios.
Thank you guys for,
uh,
you know,
they've been hooking me up here.
I've been playing drums over there when I can,
while I'm in town.
Keep my chops up.
You know,
I have to for all the gigs I don't have and a,
and what dad and with debt.
It's freckles birthday.
And,
uh,
I got a nice birthday gift early last night when the Bruins came out,
took it to the blues and won game six and an incredible atmosphere in St Louis.
I mean,
they pulled out all the stops as you knew they would.
They had Brett Hall who was hilarious and I don't understand people like sorta
teasing them with his enthusiasm and just immediately thinking that he was
absolutely shit faced.
That guy was always outspoken.
He was always hilarious and he was,
he's not introverted.
I'm not saying he didn't have a couple,
two or three,
but who cares.
He was having a great time,
like voice cracked.
I smoked a cigar last night.
I was having a great time.
Um,
and yeah,
those fans were on the edge of their seats.
They wanted the cup and the Bruins had their backs to the wall and uh,
figured out a way to beat him.
And now it is game seven on Wednesday.
So you know,
who's going to win?
Who the hell knows?
All I know is we made some adjustments to what they were doing.
So you learn more in a loss than you do in a victory.
So Berbee is going to make his adjustments and we'll see.
We'll see what happens on Wednesday.
I was so frigging nervous during that game where I,
uh,
you know,
even when we went up a couple of goals,
I always knew the blues here.
So we seem to have this ability to,
after you score a goal,
they come right back down and they score it just really just,
it just takes the momentum out of what you did.
And I literally said to my buddy,
I was watching the game,
it was like,
we need a garbage golf.
We just need a garbage goal.
And we got one fucking knuckle ball that was,
came in like Phil Negro through it.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
that was a garbage goal.
But,
um,
other than that,
it was a nice solid victory for us.
But,
um,
this series has been too back and forth to feel comfortable on either side.
Um,
but there's going to be a game seven Stanley Cup final in,
in a,
in Boston on Wednesday,
and the Stanley Cup is coming to the garden and somebody going home with it.
I oversee hope that it's going to be us.
Um,
you know,
either way,
if you're not a hockey,
you know,
if you,
this is a great game to tune into game seven.
Stanley Cup final doesn't get any fucking better than this.
The poor blues fans had been waiting for 51 52 years longer than this old
fucking former redheads.
Well,
I guess I'm still always going to be a right hand.
Uh,
is still alive.
Was,
has been alive,
sorry.
And,
um,
which,
right.
And when our second cup of the decade,
um,
so we shall see.
It was a,
what a game.
I S I was so fucking nervous.
I was,
you know,
we scored the first goal I was watching in a bar,
I'm not drinking now,
so I'm just drinking waters in a,
I bought a cigar.
So we smoked in between the first and second period,
put it out,
you know,
watched the second period,
re-lit it back up,
put it out and then went in for the third period.
And I,
but I spent most of the game outside the bar pacing.
Watching was never comfortable I think until we got the fourth goal was when I,
when I finally felt like I could relax a little bit and for whatever reason I
remember there was like seven minutes left for like 20 minutes it felt.
And um,
um,
at one point I remember looking in the bar looking at a different TV and I saw
Bryan Cranston and I was like,
the hell is Brian Cranston doing it?
The Stanley Cup final.
I didn't know he was a blues fan.
It looks all happy and he was wearing a bow tie,
really dressed up for the game.
I didn't realize they had the Tony Awards,
another TV.
And I got to see Bryan Cranston when to Tony.
So congratulations to him.
Um,
and how's the thought?
It was hilarious that they had the Tony Awards on in a,
in a sports bar.
You know what I mean?
Who said that?
You know,
a big dumb sports bar can't be progressive.
We had on the Tonys.
Um,
and yeah,
that was it.
And then we,
oh my God,
we somehow,
yeah.
Somehow went into their building and got a victory,
which we needed to.
So,
uh,
but they,
they're,
they're a tough team.
They are a tough team to beat.
So somehow we're going to try to be him two times in a row.
I have no idea what is going to happen on Wednesday,
but,
um,
this has been a hell of a final.
Um,
and I gotta tell you,
man,
like,
just hockey's the best fucking sport period.
That's it.
You know,
it's just,
there's nothing,
there's nothing like playoff hockey.
It's just,
it's the fucking best.
I would say a close second match madness.
Um,
just as far as like the adrenaline excitement level,
just not letting up.
But,
um,
somebody asked me,
said,
Oh,
you're from Boston,
see like all the Boston teams.
I was like,
yeah.
So he goes,
well,
who's your favorite growing up?
And I was thinking about,
I was going,
yeah,
I guess it was the Bruins.
It was always,
it was always hockey,
football.
Um,
and then basketball and baseball were tied,
I think,
not tied in a bad way.
They just,
you know,
I hated the Yankees and I hated the Lakers equally.
So I watched,
you know,
this is the one great thing.
I think the why Boston has such crazy sports fans is because when I was growing
up,
other than the Celtics,
we never won.
And not only did we not win,
but our biggest rivalries,
rivals always seem to be the most successful people,
you know,
franchises in the sport.
And we were always like the Washington generals,
like,
you know,
the Yankees had won a Zillion fucking world series and we hadn't won in forever.
And the,
our biggest rivalry rivalry with was with the fucking Yankees,
which was hilarious.
And it was a ridiculous rivalry to say it's a rivalry.
We've just,
whether we would have fucking punching bag for like fucking 80 years.
Um,
and then in hockey we could just knew we can never win in Montreal forum.
We would like regular season or play off.
We didn't win a game in their fucking building for like two decades.
It was crazy.
I'm on one time.
We had them beat and they scored in a regular season game and they like tied it
up with like two seconds to go in the game.
Back then they didn't have overtime,
just like ended a tie.
So Montreal had a zillion cops and we had like five and we hadn't won in
forever.
MMM.
And then the Celtics,
our biggest rivals with the Lakers and a,
we own them right up until 84.
But since then,
uh,
you know,
they,
they beat us in 85,
87 in 2009 and we beat him in 2008.
So they,
they turn the tide,
they won a bunch of titles and all of that Shit.
So it's just that level of,
uh,
you know,
you just hate him.
It's like if you live in Colorado,
Detroit,
how much the avalanche and the Redwings hated each other.
We had that in all four sports and the Patriots,
it was the fucking dolphins.
Believe it or not,
I don't even know if the Miami Dolphin fans even realize that those fucking
constant went from Bob Greasy couple of years.
They had day a David Woodley and don Strock,
but then he went right to Dan Marino and they just beat her fucking ass from
like the 70s,
all the seventies,
all of the 80s.
And,
and then all of a sudden Jim Kelly and the bills came along.
uh,
I dunno,
I was just,
I was just looking and we just had,
I dunno,
we did get to a Superbowl in [inaudible] 86 but then got the living shit kicked
out of us cause we finally beat the dolphins in the orange bowl.
That was nothing.
We could never went in the orange bowl.
We can never been in the Montreal forum.
We could,
we could never went in Yankee stadium.
Like just,
we had these fucking places and would just tortured.
And I think that that's why you have this.
I don't know why it's just such a great,
uh,
you need the rivalries.
I think,
you know,
I think that's why Pittsburgh's a great town sports town.
Like that Patrick Division,
they fucking hated each other.
I don't know.
I'm babbling because I'm so excited that we're,
we still have a chance to win this fucking thing.
Um,
so anyway,
uh,
moving on,
moving on here.
Um,
I didn't get to see the Formula One,
but I saw the highlight and Sebastian fettle had the fucking race one.
Lewis Hamilton was right on his ass,
of course.
And I dunno what happened if he fucked up a what looked like he fucked up.
He missed this turn and he had to go into the grass,
which is fine.
MMM.
But when he got back on the track,
Lewis was trying to pass them on the right and that'll defended,
or he said he didn't have any grip cause he had grass on his tires,
but they gave them a time penalty.
So even though he came,
he came in first,
they took the race away from him.
And,
uh,
which as a race fan socks,
I understand the call I guess,
but it sucks because it would have been nice to see Ferrari when one and make
this a little more competitive instead of given the golden boy there,
Louis Hamilton,
another fucking 25 points.
I just hope he doesn't pull away and it's like over by July.
I,
you know,
that's been a frustrating thing to see.
You want to see a nice fucking back and forth or at the very least between,
you know,
the two teammates there,
um,
both to us in Hamilton.
I don't know.
So,
uh,
anyway,
I'm walking around,
I'm doing this movie.
I've been having such a great time.
MMM.
And you know,
I,
the firemen mustache looks good when I'm being the guy that I'm being,
but I swear to God,
this is hilarious too because it's gay pride week when I just walk around New
York,
I look like I just looked like an old queen that never found love,
you know,
and it was,
uh,
it was pride week.
I,
you know,
I thought I'd be getting some more looks,
I'm a vain son of a bitch.
I'm a little disappointed.
The fellows work checking me out the way I thought they would go.
It's like I'm in movie shape right now.
I got a big red village people mustache,
like come on,
you know,
give me a little fucking ego boost here.
You know,
I was walking down,
was down going to do with spot over and Caroline's right.
And there was just,
you know,
it was it pride week?
Is that what it is?
I don't,
I don't know.
I'm always out of the loop with all that social shit.
But I knew it was,
it was,
it was gay pride week whenever the fucker was and say everybody's,
you know,
doing that thing.
And there was one guy just standing there and he wrote us,
he had this big fucking sign and then he wrote in small letters.
It was funny,
like he didn't use the whole canvas.
He just wrote God hates LGBT behavior
just standing there by himself.
Um,
as fucking hilarious.
That's fucking hilarious.
Just sitting there with this side,
like,
you know,
I'm a fucking curmudgeon in as much this,
a lot of shit out there that really bothers me,
but to,
to put in the fucking effort to make a sign,
you know,
by myself.
And then you just stand there.
You know?
Like,
I think that the behavior of beyond say's fans is,
you know,
when they really get on somebody,
I think it's funny that they all,
anytime anybody messes with Beyonce,
they come to her defense,
but they take it to the level that you send death threats to somebody.
You know?
It's just,
I,
I don't,
I mean,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
Do you know
what,
as much as that bothers me,
this is really a stupid comparison.
But you who's kid,
until you guys don't tune into this fucking podcast for intelligence to you,
as much as that bothers me,
I just can't imagine ever making a sign and just stand in there.
You know what I mean?
Or some sign about Seminis how fucking are hardcore feminists to some of the
most fucking sexist human beings I've ever met.
I can get political,
right,
I can say things.
I could make a sign,
we're going to go to war with fucking,
I ran when we already got bankrupt and Iraq.
Fuck are we doing and just stand there with the sign.
I mean I feel all those things,
but to actually make the site as much as I don't agree with the sign,
you know,
you got to look at somebody like that and say that that is somebody that uh,
they have an idea and they see it through and that's what all successful people
do.
Um,
and if you go and no one should follow,
that sign is for your ass alone.
Um,
and then later on,
uh,
like the next day,
oh,
you think it was the same day,
there was one guy with the megaphone yelling at bunch of anti gay shit.
And unfortunately there was some gay people that took the bait.
So just leaving the guy screaming into a fucking black hole.
And it was funny because he was yelling all this shit about Jesus.
And is there anything funnier than when somebody's yelling at Jesus fire and
Brimstone Shit.
And you catch them losing their train of thought,
let's do this guy was doing,
he was like,
I wish I could make the fucking sound effective of a,
of a megaphone or you've just going on,
I painted,
it's got to come back a better
[inaudible] I,
oh,
the guy.
Yeah.
All these fucking
huge pauses and I want to be like,
dude,
are you running out of Hay?
I think you said all your fucking hatred,
dude.
You're fucking,
you're running on fumes.
And sounded like a car running out of gas and he was doing it and do a fucking
bullhorn.
I walked by and I was crying,
laughing
cause then there was like,
you know,
a bunch of,
there was some drunk gay guys,
shut up,
you have fun call.
And he's like,
Jesus
drove a bro.
You don't cry.
Put my photos.
I put my penis where bulldogs or whatever the fuck he was saying.
Um,
it really made me Miss New York,
just seeing those kinds of interactions.
And,
uh,
we went,
we went to central park or is I called it when I first got back to your grand
central park because they haven't been here so long,
just combining the train station with their park.
And,
uh,
I had a great day yesterday.
We took my daughter to dance class and I was out there dancing around doing all
the daddy shit with her.
And then,
uh,
she went to bed and then I went down to Rivington music and I played some this,
um,
and during her nap and then I came back and we went to central park and uh,
took a horse and carriage ride,
uh,
me,
the wife and my daughter.
And uh,
it was funny,
the guys go in and it's like a 45 minute ride
and we were like,
oh,
all right,
cool,
great.
And um,
okay.
He ends up starting to tell us,
he goes,
you want me to tell you,
hang on a second.
Okay.
How do you hit pause on this thing?
I got a new fucking recorder.
I don't want to hit pause cause then I'm gonna have to fucking
yeah.
Added to shit back together.
I don't,
I don't want to do this Mike Birthday.
Okay.
People,
I'm not fucking doing that stuff.
We don't have any tissues still.
We
got to go with the fucking toilet paper here in God.
Oh,
I got the echo here in Jesus does lack.
Yeah.
Alright.
So,
so we get to the park and it's supposed to be a 45 minute tour,
but because really,
yeah.
Do,
we lived here for like 12 years.
You don't need to point out the carousel and all that shit.
We know it is.
So he didn't say anything and the fucking thing was done in like 18 minutes.
Uh,
but it was still fun because,
um,
it was funny.
My daughter,
she wanted to see the horse,
so that was her big thing cause she loves,
you know,
riding horse riding ponies.
And I kept saying to her going,
hey,
we're gonna,
we're going to go to,
we're going to go to central park and uh,
take right on the wagon.
She would call it a wagon and see the,
uh,
you know,
and see the horses and she goes,
she goes,
ride the ponies.
I go,
yeah,
we're going to go there when it comes to try and get her to say,
see the Horsey.
So she wouldn't think she was going.
She just kept going and I ride,
ride the ponies like dead serious.
Oh my God.
She's at such a frigging cute age.
Such a cute age.
Well my,
my wife dances around,
she goes,
go mommy,
go mommy.
And uh,
yesterday she,
you know,
she ate her dinner and then she wanted some more of Nias and stuff and we do
this like,
no,
you don't,
you hate your dinner.
You'd done.
Um,
and she goes,
I want to smoothly,
I want movie.
Like he can't have a smoothie.
Okay,
you already ate,
you know,
uh,
he could have some more broccoli is I want,
I want to smooth.
We were like,
you can't,
you can have some more broccoli if you want it.
And she just goes and she goes,
why not?
And we just go,
because,
you know,
she just got,
she got mad for half a second.
She goes,
mommy,
she goes,
why not?
And then my knee at gave her that mother look and then she got all innocence.
She just goes,
please,
ah,
she's killing.
She's funnier than I am.
She doesn't even know it yet.
So,
um,
anyhow,
what I'm gonna Start Up,
I've done here.
Is it time for the ad reads?
No,
not quite yet.
So,
uh,
so then we went there and uh,
all the gay dudes were up.
There are,
a lot of them were up there,
right?
All the gay dudes,
every single one of them.
America was in central park.
Um,
oh,
we were actually riding on the horse and we went by sh,
uh,
was it cheap?
Sheep's whatever fucking field where they used to bring the sheep,
have meet the fucking grass,
I guess.
Sheep's Bay meto well,
I don't know what the fuck it's called.
And I looked over,
I didn't really notice anything.
And Nia started laughing.
I said,
what?
She goes out,
she goes,
well,
I was sitting here wondering why,
why are there so many shirtless white people over there?
And she goes,
I just realized it's pride week.
I looked over,
there was like a zillion gay guys with their shirts off
all in like gay shape,
you know,
like fucking shredded and shit.
And we got off.
There was this couple that was just like intertwined,
you know,
like when snakes try to see who is stronger,
who gets to fuck the female.
These just sorta like it's fucking,
it was wanting to fund one of the funniest fights ever because they don't have
arms or legs or anything and they just sit there trying to push each other down.
There was these two people,
I thought it was a man and a woman and they had the little boombox and they will
listen to all these fucking,
uh,
what was the fucking song,
fuck.
One of those classic,
Hilarious love songs by like Christopher Cross or something.
And they had it so loud that I looked over when and both their heads popped up
and they both had mustaches like mine.
Um,
anyway,
so I had like,
I feel like yesterday was my birthday,
you know,
the Bruins one,
I saw that great people watching.
MMM.
The guy with the megaphone running out of ideas.
I mean,
just like,
that's like,
if you can come up with that as a comedian,
I mean that's just like a fucking brilliant character or something like that.
And uh,
I dunno,
it really is.
I don't know.
It's just so much funny shit out there.
You don't,
some fucking guy in the New York Post
decided he was going to rip David Mamet.
Like he was this hacky fucking writer or something.
So ma'am,
it has some new play.
It's a comedy and it's,
it's based on like the Harvey Weinstein thing.
And he goes,
that's right.
It's a comedy based on Harvey Weinstein's behavior and proceeds to write how out
of fucking touchy is,
you know,
and it's just like,
like what?
You don't even understand what the fuck like so,
so many people out there who don't even understand
all the different levels of humor and the purpose of humor and how humor can be
used in very stressful,
sad things.
You know,
they just look at humor in a one dimensional way.
You made fun of that.
That means you don't care.
That's,
that's the only way they look at it.
So the only thing that should be made fun of is just inanimate objects because
we make fun of any fucking thing else.
That means that like,
you know,
you obviously don't give a shit about it and they have no idea that there's just
like music.
There's all different kinds of fucking humor and some shit.
It's so sad you have to joke about it or rush,
you're going to go fucking crazy.
That's why people at war,
you know,
cops on in murder scenes will make a joke.
I remember one time this person I went to high school with was,
uh,
worked for the state as a defense attorney.
And this guy had beaten like I,
this terrible thing had beaten is,
uh,
like toddler to death and they had to come up with the defense.
Oh,
that's right.
Because she'd seen me and these fucking assholes.
We're taking my shit seriously.
And I,
and I was telling how people don't understand humans.
She goes,
I totally get it.
we had to come up with defense for this guy who beat his toddler to death.
And she said,
we were sitting there and it was just so absurd that they started saying how the
toddler was coming at the guy and he felt threatened.
And it was just so fucking ridiculous that they all started crying,
laughing.
And it isn't because you don't care.
It's because the fucking thought of it is just so fucking overwhelming.
Okay.
Yeah.
If you don't laugh,
you're gonna cry.
Right.
And what is so fucking ridiculous for this guy to have this outrage?
First of all,
David Mamet who was a fucking genius,
never fucking outrage that he would choose,
um,
the Harvey Weinstein story as,
as a topic for,
for a fucking play and have that level of outrage.
Why the fucking producers is like one of the greatest all time plays ever.
That was based off of the fucking Holocaust.
I mean,
what the fuck?
I can't believe that person wrote that article in the editor.
Never at any point was just like,
uh,
you know,
how can we criticize this when the producers is out there?
Okay.
I don't,
I don't fucking know what I think it really comes down to unfortunately is most
papers are just highly politicized.
I'm sure David Mamet had some considered some sort of lefty or something,
so they decided to do that or he was just roadkill in their attack on Hollywood
fucking people.
I have no fucking idea,
but it's kind of struck me as funny as just like,
all right,
well that's based on sexual harassment.
This one's based on the Holocaust,
so you don't have a problem with that.
Okay.
Well,
it's because he was Jewish and he wrote it there for you can do it.
Shut up.
Shut the fuck up.
All right.
Plenty of other people also died.
Um,
for some reason they don't count them.
I feel like in World War II,
all the people that the Germans killed that warrant,
Jewish people are,
are,
they're almost like a NFL titles.
Like for some reason they don't count them.
They only count fucking Superbowls.
It's really,
it's a strange thing.
All right,
we got to read here in
Dope Chino Indochino talk about how every man looks better.
It feels more confident when he puts on a suit.
Well,
I know that I do,
and I wish I'd put one on yesterday,
honey for gay pride.
So I would have got some more looks from my red mustachioed self,
you know?
Yeah.
That's what I should've done.
Put on a nice suit.
You know,
walk around looking like a gay,
Rusty Jones,
a bald gay,
Rusty Jones.
Indochino is the world's most exciting made to measure men's wear company.
We make suits and shirts to your exact measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort.
Here's how it works.
Does that a stylist at our showroom over 40 show rooms in North America,
they're very proud of that even though there's 50 states and have them take your
meds.
Some of you might be driving a little bit.
Take your measurements personally,
our measure at home yourself and shop online as I you do it.
If they don't have a place as a showroom and your state,
you can do it online and shop online@indochino.com choose your fabric inside and
out.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices.
Relax while you suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you and a couple
of weeks this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 359 bucks@indochino.com
when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus free
shipping plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code bar for any premium suit for just 359 bucks and
free shipping.
Incredible deal for a premium made to measure suit.
Once you go custom,
you don't go back.
It's funny.
I thought that was going to rhyme.
Okay.
Uh,
why don't you go custom.
You're going to be busted him.
Once you go custom,
you're going to bust them interface or his face or these face.
Look at that as a progressive read right there.
All right.
Um,
all right,
let's do some fucking reads here for the week.
Can we do some reads?
How much time do I got left here?
Oh,
Jesus.
I got a whole half an hour.
Uh,
I got a whole half an hour there,
uh,
from Nigeria.
Nice.
I might,
when I first moved to New York,
I had a Nigerian roommate who was a big time hockey player.
Really good hockey player.
All right.
What's up Billy birthday,
boy,
thank you for that birthday wishes from a firm on the other side of the planet.
It's also my birthday to look at that.
Another June 10th person.
I just want to ask you from some advice on my career choices.
All right.
I really want to go into animation.
Uh,
but I have developed a love for acting.
I know you do both comedy and acting.
So I just want to ask if it's reasonable to do both or a pain in the ass.
Uh,
thank you for your response.
My name is Gabriel and I'm 17,
well 18 now and from Nigeria.
Thank you again birthday mate.
Um,
all right.
First of all,
the fact that you know what you want to do or you've narrowed it down to two
things,
that just 18 years of age is a huge advantage.
Um,
okay.
You know,
back in the day it used to be you kinda had to pick a road.
you are you,
he's a writer.
This guy's in a,
he's a television actor,
this guy's a movie star.
Now you can do whatever you want to do.
So,
um,
I can tell you doing stand up and doing an animated show definitely takes up a
lot of my time.
Um,
but I am able to do it and I have a wife and a child,
so I'm assuming you're not married and don't have a kid.
So I say you,
you just keep following your heart.
I mean,
both of those are two really,
really,
really fun jobs.
So no matter which one you pick,
you're going to have a great time.
Um,
I will say,
I do remember watching Louis C K s career and I was first a fan of his amazing
stand up when I saw him on the half hour MTV,
half hour comedy hour.
Then I,
then I remember he wrote for Letterman for awhile,
a little bit.
And also,
uh,
the Dana Carvey show.
And I remember thinking like,
why is why,
I mean that's cool.
He's writing for those shows,
but this guy's a star.
He should,
he should be the guy coming out doing the monologue.
And then after that he then worked for the Chris rock show and he was like
directing and all of that stuff.
And every time I would see him when he would pop into the clubs,
it was,
she was just immediately one of the best guys I'd ever seen now second,
like,
and I was thinking of my young brain,
why is he wasting his time doing these things?
And then
like five years after that when he started putting out special ops,
special ops special,
and then he got his TV shows and he was the writer,
the director,
the actor.
And the whole thing was just like,
oh,
I get,
he learned the whole business and now he's going to take his voice and apply it
to all these things that he learned how to do.
So using that as,
as a game plan,
I would think that um,
uh,
there's nothing wrong with doing both a year,
age,
18 years old,
who the hell knows what they want to do at 18?
So I would,
I would go full force into both throw yourself into them and um,
you know,
we listened to your heart.
It'll tell you which way to go.
Listen to you gun.
It gets the best,
you know,
you got your heart can sometimes be like,
your heart gets broken,
right?
You got is always sitting there going,
I fucking told you
you didn't listen to me.
Didn't listen to me.
Um,
all right,
my girl is blowing me better now.
Jesus Christ.
Hey Billy,
blow me wanting to say thank you.
My girlfriend and I were listening to you talking about blow jobs and while
she's always been a trooper,
since listening,
she's been really attacking the task with vigor now.
Jesus,
more effort and more frequency.
We didn't even really talk about it after listening,
but man,
the result is amazing.
Anyway,
and then he put the S.
Anyways,
thanks for shining a light on this topic.
You're truly doing God's work.
Sincerely,
my empty balls.
All right sir.
Well,
I'm glad you're having a good time,
but what was lacking in that email was you thank and your girlfriend for the you
.
You heard noticeably better effort and you
reciprocate.
And by taking the downtown train there,
just make sure you know it's gotta be even Steven,
that buddy.
All right,
I'm just going to fucking lay there like an emperor.
I don't know how long she's going to be into that.
Um,
all right.
What else?
You know,
Jesus,
Venice,
California.
All right,
dear Billy garbage can,
um,
send me jaded as a teen,
I volunteered at shelters and focused education on civil engineer and city
planning.
Look at me qualifying myself.
I'm almost 40 now and I've been around the problem long enough to see some
things won't change.
It take hours to me to break down all the things that have proven to work or not
work and combating homelessness instead.
A little humor.
Maybe I read this article a almost spit out my coffee.
The idea is a product of people who want the vanity of progressive forms of
community charity with none of the logic.
The funny part is the guy who wrote,
I think you meant wrote it.
The author opens with an anecdote about a young man who was sleeping on a couch
that was being moved around the alley outside his apartment and how he and a
neighbor made sure to get rid of that couch.
I imagine to send a message,
I imagine,
to send a message,
do not sleep here.
He goes on to say that to blame the heartless federal government for polling foe
.
He then goes on to say that to,
Oh dude,
this is so interesting and you didn't fucking proofread it.
He then goes on to blame the heartless federal government for pulling funding.
Then the local suit,
dope,
want to support new housing while discussing proposed high rise that would take
the place of a parking lot on Venice beach.
They want to put up to 140 unit transitional living building,
which the authors seems to be in favor,
favor of.
You don't need my background.
This issues to understand the problem with that.
You can just watch American gangster,
the white man's plan to stack people up who have very little on top of each
other really backfired.
The author who had no desire to have someone sleeping on a couch next to a
dumpster behind his apartments finishes off with,
I would so much rather that young man who dragged the blue couch next to my
house for a good night's sleep,
have a bed in a shelter instead.
You see the irony,
right?
Yeah.
He wants to get that guy to fuck out of his world.
He doesn't give a fuck.
No,
he doesn't.
He just pretends to give a fuck.
If he did,
he would have asked the young man if he needed anything or at least left the
goddamn couch.
Shalom.
Thank you.
I have to read this fucking article now.
This is just a classic thing that's like,
you know,
I've been teasing all these feminists here in New York who have outraged for
what's going on in Alabama.
It's like,
since when have you given a fuck about Alabama?
Okay.
The school systems,
they're funding.
Everything has been fucked up since the civil war.
Meaning your entire life,
you haven't given a shit.
Now you give a shit because there's something going on down there that could
potentially affect you.
All right.
Okay.
Let's,
let's read this little thing here.
Um,
the blue couch appeared one evening at the dumpster across the alley behind my
couch.
Over the course of the next two days,
the couch was moved around a bit.
By the third day,
someone had dragged the couch to the side of my house,
a not particularly private space.
The next morning as I took my niece to school,
we noticed that a young man,
presumably homeless,
was asleep on the couch.
Well,
I don't think he's a hydride couch builder who was taking a nap between fabrics.
I just heard a report on KPCC about how homeless can exacerbate or even cause
mental illness,
not the other way around.
One factor the report said is the lack of sleep suffered by people with no place
to lay their heads.
I left the kid alone.
I was going to give him some food,
but when I checked an hour later,
he was gone.
My neighbor and I dragged the couch back into the alley.
I called the city within a day.
The sanest sanitation department picked it up in some residential neighborhoods,
have this sprawling city.
I suppose it's possible to look away from homeless crisis the way you did.
I was going to give him some food.
You had food in your apartment.
You didn't do it.
I was going to give him some food.
Basically covered his ass for when he calls the city to have the fucking,
the sanitation department pick the fucking thing up so he can get rid of this
guy.
But to play devil's advocate,
he does have a kid.
He doesn't know if this guy's dangerous or whatever.
Who the fuck knows?
Right.
Anyway,
uh,
in some residential enables of this pharmacy,
I suppose it's possible to look away from the homeless crisis here in Venice.
It is not at home price.
As home prices continue their exorbitant March upward as rent skyrocket and
short term rentals like airbnb displaced longtime Venice tenants from their rent
stabilized units.
More and more people are facing a homeless crisis,
none of their own making.
Um,
all right.
I want to read the rest of this shit is getting too long.
Yeah,
it is fucking terrible.
I don't fucking know,
you know,
but I cow watch.
Can I make fun of him when I'm not doing anything about the homeless problem?
I mean,
I give people money occasionally.
Sometimes I do.
I always try to like figure out is this person under the influence because I
don't want like a,
you know,
I don't want to help get,
give you money that took to go buy something that you're going to just use to
kill yourself.
But,
um,
I dunno.
I guess I'm better than this guy because I don't pretend to care.
Who knows?
I don't know.
I just started reading that article and I realized as much as I want to make fun
of him,
that I'm kind of full of shit too.
Um,
I actually,
it goes down,
it goes up to the,
you know,
it doesn't make any fucking sense how expensive everything is getting.
It's just a,
it just doesn't make any sense.
And what is causing everybody else the problem with capitalism,
not even capitalism,
all forms of government.
Cause there's always no matter what you can have socialism,
there's still people on the top taking more than they should.
And there's always going to be hookups and fucking angles and racism and sexism
and all of that fucking shit.
Right.
Um,
and what it always ends up creating is a fuck or be fucked pyramid.
And if you can somehow figure out a way,
mmm.
Like here's something for you,
why isn't helping people profitable?
You know,
everybody's just running on the fucking wheel so they don't face plant and get
trampled by the people behind them.
So to try and stop and help somebody,
you feel like you're going to get run over.
I Dunno.
I also think that,
you know,
I could probably look into it more and there has to be a way Jesus spelled,
I mean,
you don't work every day.
You could take a couple of those hours and go help some people out.
Right.
All right.
US economy.
Um,
speaking of which,
I still am fond of fucking public school and having talked to anybody about it
and I said I was going to do a show,
so I have to make that happen to us.
I'm full of Shit,
US economy.
Hey Bill.
Hey Baby.
Uh,
I just like to give you some friendly insight on the current state of our
economy.
You often say that our country is bankrupt and your last podcast got pretty
passionate about the w about being worried about it.
I'm a financial adviser and just studied economics in school.
I know what it means.
I know everything.
Right.
Uh,
I'm going to assume when you say we are bankrupt,
you are referencing the amount of debt we currently hold as a country.
Yes.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
We do indeed hold quite a bit of debt
buddy.
Every fucking August for like nine years in a row.
The government shutdown.
Yeah.
And our only solution was to legally raise the amount of debt that this country
could take.
All right,
now I know.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about,
but let's,
let's not fucking put Zino.
Let's not put on the kid gloves.
Just give it to me straight.
All right.
We do hold quite a bit of debt.
$22 trillion is quite a bit.
Uh,
this is broken up into different types of debt,
public debt and government debt.
Public debt is the type of debt that other countries hold like China and Japan.
Well,
I didn't know that.
That's good.
So people actually oldest always money.
They each hold a little over a trillion each.
Oh,
good.
So now we're down to 20 trillion.
Uh,
you've probably heard the rhetoric of,
well,
what if China gets mad and dumps our debt into the mark,
dumps our debt to the market that would fuck up bond prices in yields?
I've probably heard that.
Who the fuck do you think I'm hanging out with?
I don't know what any of that means.
How can you dump our debt to the market?
What market?
Well,
the little piggies cove,
this little piggy went to market.
This little piece stayed home and China dumped fucking dollar their debt to us
and I don't know what the fuck that means.
Sure.
Very temporarily.
Yeah,
and then we would either back that 1 trillion or find another alley to buy it
up.
It's not enough to crash our market,
not even close.
Then there is our government debt where it's mainly our agency's holdings,
like social security,
medicare,
disability,
et cetera.
This is about 30% of our overall debt.
Well,
how much is paying $1 billion a fucking week or whatever and these goddamn never
ending fucking wars
that we just keep starting.
Yeah.
With no real
like
the war against terror is is it's just,
okay,
it's wide open.
US being over there creates more terrorism so it becomes never ending.
I just,
I feel like if we just my,
this is my stupid barroom logic.
If we just got the fuck out of the Middle East and I know everybody well,
we just can't just up and leave all of those people like it.
We'll look what the fuck we done to him in the process of trying to get the bad
guys,
how many fucking innocent people were killed over there.
If we get the fuck out of there,
we commit to electric and solar power,
which I'm not even saying is cleaner.
It's just not what they're selling over there.
That fucking really affects their goddamn economy.
It would affect ours too,
I guess because of all the oil companies.
So I just say you give all the solar shit,
you give the son,
you give the son to the oil companies here.
Okay.
And you invest in them switching over to that form of fucking energy
and Middle East.
That's the number one export.
Then they go bankrupt.
They don't have enough fucking money to fuck with us.
And after we're gone for a while,
they'll just go back to fighting each other.
The same way.
When Russia left fucking eastern Europe,
Bosnians and Serbs picked right the fuck up where they were before those guys
were there and they were there for like fucking 70 years or something,
something like that.
Eight years.
I have no fucking idea.
That's my solution.
All right.
And you know,
considering I don't even know what the fuck you're talking about.
I should probably shut up.
All right.
Okay.
Now let's talk about why that much debt isn't a big problem for the u s instead
of boring you with a bunch of dumb numbers.
No.
Bore me.
Educate me.
He goes,
I'll give you an example.
Oh,
they,
oh,
I love this.
He's going to dumb it down to my level.
Let's say you're sitting there in the second period and he got half a beer and
you got to take a pen.
All right?
Uh,
but you don't want to miss the Empty Netta.
Who pulls the goalie in the second period?
Patrick,
why does,
all right,
uh,
now let's talk about why that did out of,
okay,
I'll give you an example.
It's like a guy with $50,000 in credit and a credit card debt,
but only $5,000 in the bank.
Yeah,
that's terribly okay.
He goes awful position to be in obviously.
But that same guy owns $1 million house free and clear with no mortgage.
The equity has in that house alone could cover the debt easily.
Yeah,
but at some point you're gonna have to sell the fucking house.
Right.
Is the house our country?
I'm lost.
Now you asked the question as to why when he just pay off those debts.
Then I didn't ask that question,
but thank you for asking.
For me and the U s scenario,
debt is a way of leverage and collateral with other countries.
It's bargaining chips that can bring other ideas to the table.
Also,
the u s has never missed an interest payment on this debt.
Okay.
But a bunch of other shit has been slashed and cut.
Am I crazy?
I mean,
look at,
look at our public school systems.
Look at mental health institutions.
Look at health care.
Okay.
Social Security's not going to be there by the time I fucking need it.
What are you talking to him?
Yeah,
so then they they,
this is like the thing.
Yeah,
they have all this debt so now they can't take their,
they're not taking care of their citizens as well as they used to.
Right.
God,
I wish this was,
I could talk to you about this and you could make me feel better cause it's you.
You don't seem worried about this at all.
He said,
now I'll give you the,
the Hoo Rah American stats and if we do miss an interest payment,
who's going to foreclose on us?
I don't know.
The United States has assets that blow its debt numbers out of the water.
Last time I checked,
we owned around 34% of the global wealth.
Our earning power is Riddick.
W w what do you mean we own it?
Yeah.
Our government owns it or corporations own it.
I don't understand this.
Our earning power is ridiculous and our growth is unprecedented.
Everyone has been expecting our GDP
too slow because markets are cynical and we have been in the longest bull run in
history.
Then this last quarter we dropped 3.2% I don't even know what the GED,
I know gross natural products.
Is it gross domestic product?
What does that mean?
I gotta look that up.
I'm want to look this up like if I know what this means,
I'm going to understand what the fuck you talking about.
ECON.
Nomi g d p meaning
weighing in at gross domestic product.
Oh,
I got it right.
Look at that.
I and you have to phone a friend.
Oh I did.
Cause I had to confirm it.
Yeah.
Everyone who's been expecting our gross domestic product to slow because he's
marked markets is cynical who've been in the longest bull run in the history.
Then this last quarter we dropped
83.2% gross domestic product,
which is honestly incredible,
is reflective of our resilience of our country is at making money.
We aren't bankrupt bill far from it.
Should we go into war with Iran?
No,
but we aren't bankrupt.
When you say we,
what do you mean by we?
What about the 2008 banking crisis and the amount of people in America who are
upside down in their houses.
So basically what you're saying to me is that your heads above water and my
head's above water.
So then we shouldn't care about all the Americans who are drowning in debt.
Is that what you're telling me?
All of these social uh,
programs that have been cut,
all of this,
this is what you're telling me.
I mean,
I don't know.
I try not to do that shit where,
hey,
I'm doing okay.
So everything's great.
I Dunno.
But I also know that you know more about this shit than I do.
He said if you want sources on any of these stats I loosely through at you,
I'll give it to you.
I just figured you didn't want to take 30 minutes on the subject.
I've been listening to the podcast since 2010 and senior live twice.
Big Fan and hope your family's well.
Well,
you know something.
If I did,
I,
I imagine Joe Rogan has had a person like this on as a guest.
Rather than listen to me fucking swim in this shit and not even know what he's
talking about.
By the way,
did you see Joe Rogan,
the Joe Rogan podcast,
the Joe Rogan experience?
He has advertising on a fucking stock car.
How incredible is that?
These stupid little things that we started and how far some people have.
I mean,
I'm still the fucking guy just sitting there talking to myself,
but some of these guys,
Mark Marin had the president as a guest.
It's unbelievable.
Um,
a veteran's perspective,
by the way,
all you young comics out there,
you young,
standup comics,
you young performers,
all right,
starting out,
manager and agent comes towards you.
Do not give them a cut of your podcast money.
You're going to grow all of that by yourself.
They're trying to insert themselves into this.
All this fucking phone here is God damn phone.
You don't have to do it.
You can grow these things on your own and you can fucking,
you can fucking have all of the money to yourself.
All right,
let them stay with a fucking belong,
okay.
And Film and TV and the way that they have fucking over writers and the way
they've packaged all of these shows together and they were actually making more
money than,
than the performers on the show.
And a lot of cases shows you where their hearts are at.
So fuck them.
So they can't get old guys like us cause they didn't know what podcasts are
going to be.
But what now they're going to try to do is sign you to across the deal boards,
do not give up your podcast money.
Fuck them.
Just say that's,
that's,
that's a deal breaker.
And all you young people should together and say that that is a fucking for once
for fucking ones.
Cause those fucking pieces of shit are gonna figure out a fucking way that
somehow they're going to end up owning your podcast and they're going to end up
getting more fucking money.
The fucking check is going to come with their fucking name on it.
I'm gonna tell you right now,
that is how business works.
You get in business with somebody bigger than you.
They all,
you know,
we're in business together to make money off these guys.
How it works is then the fucking money that has made always goes to the other
comment that you get into business with.
Okay.
And then they send you a fucking check with their name on it.
And that is the quintessential behind the music.
How did it get stolen from?
And then you go to them to get a raise and then they can somehow fudge the
fucking numbers and say that you're not in fucking profit.
And they,
and then you fucking audit them and then you find out that this stealing from
you.
And they'll come back the next day with a smile on the face and just be like,
this is how business is done.
All right.
And that is the purpose of all things comedy.
We try to create a place where fucking comedians could keep their podcasts and
these fucking Goddamn fucking leaches couldn't come in and try and steal your,
they can't even just accept a portion of it.
They fucking want all of it.
I,
I swear to God,
dude,
this is why,
this is why I do this business the way I fucking do it.
Sit here talking to my fucking self.
I try to do everything by myself because every time I get in fucking business
with somebody,
all they do is these the fucking steal from you.
There is not one aspect in this fucking business that I have ever been involved
in where somebody is doing a standup date doing fucking podcasting.
I've been,
I've been good.
Okay.
Cause I was able to fucking circle the wagons,
right?
Acting,
creating a show,
working on a show.
I,
there's never,
I've never not gotten stolen from every fucking,
every fucking time you think this is.
They've run out of ways to do it.
And this is what kills me.
Cause if fucking sociopathic fucking pieces of shit,
they go to sleep at night,
they sleep like a fucking baby.
Absolute fucking scumbags.
So if I can tell you that all you fucking young people coming up in this fucking
business,
all right?
All of those fucking cops out there,
okay?
Do not give away your podcasts.
Money.
Fucking greedy,
dirty bastards.
All right.
A veteran's perspective.
Hey Bill,
how's it going?
I was thinking about what you and your wife were talking about,
the cognitive dissonance between Americans and in their politics and the field
of psychology,
cognitive,
cognitive.
What,
who at what point did somebody that I say something smart last week,
I've never had emails like this and my life,
cognitive dissonance is the mental discomfort,
psychological stress experienced by a person who holds two or more contradictory
beliefs or values.
Is this a fancy way of saying I'm out of my mind?
Uh,
this discomfort is triggered by a situation in which a person's belief clashes
with new evidence perceived by the person when confronted with facts that
contradict beliefs,
ideals and values.
People will try to find a way to resolve the contradictions,
to reduce their discomfort.
Oh,
God knows I do that.
Uh,
I think the book media politics by
Shanto.
Yeah,
I younger.
That looks like an l l y linger or is that a l or an I?
I guess that's an eye.
I Y e.
N.
G.
A.
R a professor of political science from Stanford.
Would ease your frustration and understanding how they brand sees the big six
media conglomerates use information and psychology to benefit the bottom line of
financially motivated networks.
Aren't they all financially motivated?
Um,
except for PBS man.
They have a fucking fundraiser telethon.
When I wasn't dropping acid and ecstasy in the hills of the eight oh five I was
in a classroom full of exchange students from Sweden,
China,
and Mexico and a bunch of other places.
They knew far more than I ever learned in my k 12 experience about our politics
and the intertwined relationship between lobbyists,
brand representative,
politicians,
advocates for legislator and bureaucracy,
government agency.
Essentially,
Mr
Iyengar says you have to buy your blue,
red,
green,
rainbow POW and American flags from the same company who funds the campaigns of
politician who then push funds for agencies and committees for example,
because banks costs,
wait for example,
because banks costs all sides money.
Why have overdraft fees gone from 1520 in the early two thousands to 34 to $36
in 2019 they have made record profits and didn't have to accept the feet.
In 2008.
How did that happen as the late and great Patrice Neha would sit,
O'Neill would say gas is high because you know,
what are you going to do?
Hope this helps.
I love the podcast and your comedy is good therapy.
Best a veteran who enjoys your stand up.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
I might actually,
am I going to read a book?
The one that isn't like Mike.
The next book on my,
on my list is the Ken Stabler autobiography.
That's the next one on my hit list.
But maybe I should actually throw something like this.
And you know,
it's funny,
as you all know,
I'm reading a fucking smart book like this because all of a sudden I'll start,
I'll try to start sounding smart in this podcast and the whole thing will go off
the rails.
Um,
vindictive woman.
I'm a lady.
Oh,
I love when the ladies right in.
I've been saying for years it doesn't happen enough.
Uh,
when I went in my twenties,
a boyfriend put a brick through my windshield,
first night in my new place
without him.
What?
When in my twenties at boyfriend,
put a brick through my windshield first night in my new place without him.
Meaning you guys had broken up or you just had the audacity to have a night just
for you?
I responded by getting a temporary restraining order on him and went to his
favorite watering hole.
He went to nightly.
Well that's kind of dangerous.
Advised him I would be there every night until he paid for my replacement
windshield.
Okay.
That's a gangster fucking move.
Basically taken his home away from home from him.
He did pay,
but even though I had heard he got a new apartment and checked his account at
the bank.
Wait,
he did pay.
But even though I had heard he got a new apartment and checked his account at
the bank,
what the fuck does that mean?
Place stop pay on his rent.
Check in the new apartment to get even love everything you do.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Wait,
wait.
Why?
What'd,
what'd you do?
I missed what happened.
I,
I feel like when people,
this is like the last episode of lost.
What happened?
I don't get what just happened there.
You got a restraining order and then went to his,
to his favorite bar every night.
You advise them that you'd be there every night until he paid for the
replacement windshield.
Gangster fucking move and allow any person in law enforcement of security would
say dangerous fucking move.
So don't do that ladies.
All right.
Cause you're going to get the guy who doesn't give a fuck and it will be like,
oh,
so now I know where you're going to be so I can go down and do something
horrible to you.
All right.
Basically taking his home away from home,
away from him.
He did pay,
I think she was trying to say,
even though he did pay though,
I heard he got a new apartment and I checked his account at the bank,
placed a stop payment on his rent check and his new apartment to get even.
Oh,
I love everything you do and go fuck yourself.
Well,
I mean,
okay.
That is fucking amazing.
All right.
It's not smart and it's not mature.
Um,
and you got away with it.
So good on you.
But I would not do that because one of these days you're gonna run into the
fucking person that doesn't give a fuck watch casino and watched that Joe Pesci
monologue when he talks to that guy,
what the fuck he's going to do them and they're going to send me to jail and
Yada Yada Yada.
In seven years,
you know,
later I'm going to come out and I'm going to fucking do it again because I'm a
fucking lunatic.
Like when somebody doesn't give you date somebody,
um,
I dunno,
it's my belief when you break up with somebody that say you get the fuck away
from where you do not try to make their life miserable or whatever,
he did throw a brick through your windshield,
you did the proper thing,
you got a restraining order.
Um,
but I will say going down to his favorite bar,
yeah.
Every night.
So we can't go there is funny as that is,
is for your own personal safety is a really reckless thing to do.
Um,
and also letting him know that you're doing that and just deliberately rubbing
it in the face of somebody who did something pretty fucking violent.
I would be worried where the next brick was going to go.
So,
uh,
in the future,
you know,
it looks like he got away with it.
I would not.
Uh,
and also what you're doing is making him more of an angry human being and he's
probably gonna treat.
Yeah,
I dunno.
People even worse on his next one.
So you're,
you're combating negative energy with more negative energy.
So I would be,
I would be careful with that.
It made for a good read.
It was a funny fucking story.
But,
uh,
yeah,
being of addictive person is,
it's not a good character trait and eventually you do it to the wrong person and
that can be grave consequences.
All right.
And that's all I'm going to say on that.
And evidently I have some books to read here.
Uh,
gold Bruins.
Go Bruins gold.
Grow ends.
Go Brolin's,
go Bruins,
go Bruins.
That's all I can say.
And I am so psyched for this game.
Seven.
Um,
hopefully I won't be working on the movie and I will be standing outside a
sports bar for most of it.
Looking into the fucking window.
Um,
what is series?
What a sport.
Okay.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in audio on Thursday.
When I do,
there'll be a new Stanley Cup champion.
All right.